it's a stamp
i did have a couple of paragraphs of uh
lead up to that but honestly if you're
just here to find out what the most
expensive object in the world by weight
is it's this stamp there's now gonna be
several diversions about why it should
count as that what the alternatives
might be and why it's that expensive but
if you just click the video to find out
the answer to the question in the title
it's this stamp 8.3 million dollars for
about 40 milligrams the stamp's called
the british guyana one-cent magenta it's
the absolute pinnacle of rarity in stamp
collecting it's not a variant it's not a
watermark variety it's not a printing
error it's a straight normal postage
stamp of which only one survived and
that's what makes it unique so this was
actually produced at the local printer
office so it was only ever intended to
tide the colony over for a week or two
this one cent stamp also is believed
only paid a newspaper rate which meant
that they were used just to post
newspapers locally and newspapers even
back then were immediately disposable
there may be more expensive stuff by
weight antimatter is often called the
most expensive stuff in the world but i
don't think that should count here for
several reasons first there's no way for
anyone no matter how wealthy they are to
buy a gram of antimatter in the shops or
at auction second
substances aren't objects the english
language has a distinction between count
nouns and mass nouns it's the difference
between there was a dog on the road and
there was dog on the road there's
probably a less gruesome way of
explaining that but i guarantee that's
going to stay in more people's heads and
the third reason
this stamp is non-fungible even if there
was an antimatter shop just down the
road okay let's go for something more
realistic but also very expensive let's
say there's a shop selling printer ink
just down the road one gram of printer
ink is the same as any other gram
they're fungible if you switch them out
it doesn't matter this stamp is
non-fungible not just because it's the
only one left but because of its history
it's a unique object the stan was
actually first discovered in 1873 by 12
year old schoolboy
now the timing would have been nothing
unusual because over time
multiple stamps of everything else were
discovered but this is the only stamp in
british commonwealth history where no
other examples have ever turned up it
passed through an increasingly
prestigious list of the greatest names
in philatelic history stanley gibbons is
the world's oldest stamp dealership we
have an auction house
two retail teams and a coin company
called baldwin's stanley gibbons was
lucky enough to purchase the stamper
auction in new york and now it's on
display every monday wednesday and
friday just for conservation and light
reasons but indefinitely here in an
oxygen-free conservation case this stamp
has repeatedly set the record for most
expensive and every time it does it adds
another line to its already very long
history it's expensive because it's rare
yes there is only one of these in the
world and the way our society works
someone's got to own it but outside
stamp collector circles not many people
would care about the rarest stamp but
the wider world it's famous because it's
expensive and more fame will likely make
it more expensive and i guess i'm
helping that cycle continue by making
this video about it i wouldn't claim to
know the company's motivations but i'd
suspect that it's on display to the
public here at least in part because the
company is selling shares in it and more
fame will help it keep or raise its
value this is not an endorsement by the
way i approach them about filming
they've not paid me i have no desire to
buy or sell or share in a stamp but if
you want to challenge this for the most
expensive object in the world by weight
and take the very very tiny crown well
the first step would be finding
something even lighter than 40
milligrams but just as historic and just
as non-fungible
good luck
[Music]
you